As I said, L3, by proof of construction, systematically debunks all of
the myths I detailed in the previous slide. The first myth is the border
crossing myth. That is, the user space to kernel space switching. Now L
3 accomplishes this boarder crossing in
123 processor cycles. And this includes the
TLB misses that may be incurred because of
the fact that we're going from user space
to kernel space. As well as cache misses
that may be incurred because we are starting
to execute some code in the micro kernel. All of that put together, L3 shows, by
proof of construction, that you can do that
border crossing in 123 processor cycles. And L3 goes
one step further, it actually cones through
a back of the envelope calculation, what
will be the minimum cost involved in
doing this border crossing? Or, in other words,
how many cycles will the instructions that are needed, in order to do the border
crossing, take on a particular processor architecture?
And they count the number of processor cycles,
and they show that the number of processor cycles needed is about 107 and
L3 microkernel accomplishes that in 123 processor
cycles. Or, in other words, this is debunking
the myth that border crossing is going to
be expensive in microkernel based design. It's as
close to what it would take minimally in the processor, even if you hand code
through machine instructions, what needs to happen to go from the user space to
the kernel space? So that is proof that microkernel-based
design is not going to be incurring any more overhead for
border crossing. It turns out that CMU's Mach operating
system, on the same hardware, takes 900 cycles, as opposed to
the 123 cycles taken by L3 for border
crossing. Spin and exokernel that we have looked
at in fairly great detail, used Mach as
the basis for decrying microkernel based design, saying
that, well, border crossing in microkernel based design
is expensive because it takes this much time.
But what L3 has shown is that it need not take this much time, it can
be done in much shorter amount of time. Which
is close to what the hardware can actually do.